I would like to talk about America's
presidents the only group of individuals
that we know for sure at some point
masturbated in the White House oh please
you think McKinley didn't come on grow
up he's doing it in that photo listen
with all the horrors of our current
president it can sometimes help to get
some historical perspective to look at
all the people who preceded him although
a few months ago one place where you
might be able to do that was forced to
say goodbye after nearly 60 years of
operation the Hall of Presidents and
First Lady's wax museum and Gettysburg
shutting down even though the museum
will be no more you have an opportunity
to own a piece of American history
something that doesn't come up every day
in an auction for sure should be a very
interesting auction and we hope lots of
people come yeah so do I I hope that too
because these wax presidents deserve a
good home no one wants to see Benjamin
Harrison having to model culottes at
forever 21 and here's the thing people
did come some apparently paid thousands
of dollars to own a wax president and it
later turned out there were some notable
buyers among them we've got our very own
life-sized wax president that is
President Eisenhower music
is it though because to me it looks like
you may have just bought a wax sculpture
of Bill O'Reilly covering his erection
with a magazine but but it wasn't just
mother Stephen Colbert got one too and
now ladies and gentlemen leave ride for
your Late Show president Zachary Taylor
[Applause]
[Music]
well congratulations fever although it
is worth pointing out that Zachary
Taylor died of a stomach bug sixteen
months into office so he's really letter
the president and more a guy named Zach
who his brains out in the West Wing
men's room now
Colbert actually wanted Martin Van Buren
but unbeknownst to him and this is true
Jon Stewart's bought that one
perceivably to add to a big bag of
mannequin sex dungeon
that's the only rational explanation I
know what you're thinking spending good
money on a poorly made wax figure of a
former president sounds pretty stupid
right yeah you're right you're
absolutely right and that is why I am
proud to say we didn't go down there and
buy one of them
we bought fiber Wi-Fi because we are
psycho stupider than any other TV show
that's wise and the reason we've
been sitting on this for so long is
because we've been very busy
constructing a home for a horrifying new
friend in fact tonight I'd like to
present to you the last week tonight
Hall of Juvia Slee like like wax to
light
oh there is Richard Nixon he cost us
$1,900 and he looks like a full brand
Mitt Romney
next there's Bill Clinton ought to be
more accurate John Travolta in primary
colors as Bill Clinton then there's
Jimmy Carter looking like the before
photo for a jaundice medication and
William Henry Harrison who died of
pneumonia 31 days into office and this
is probably exactly what he looked like
when he did and lastly there is Warren G
Harding and you know what you
know what this one is actually my
favorite because we talked a lot about
Harvey on this program before he was our
nation's 29th president and his
administration was nearly brought down
by the Teapot Dome scandal but he
perhaps most famous for his sexual
exploits after Warren Harding died in
1923 nan Britton wrote a book claiming
she'd been his mistress they'd made love
in a White House closet and he'd
fathered her daughter Elizabeth Oh
warrant knocking up your friend's
daughter in a White House covered
you waxy little pervert but the fact is
Harding had an incredible life story and
it's a shame that someone hasn't already
made a major motion picture of it the
problem is who would do it it would have
to be someone with way too much time on
their hands way too many resources and
unfettered access to a life-size wax
replica a former president warranty
Harvey it's only that person existed the
movie they make might look a little like
this
[Music]
he came from humble roots to rule a
nation president warren g harding
and I live and breathe let's show these
fancy Washington's of what an Ohio boy
can do
[Music]
mr. speaker the President of the United
States put behind the public face with a
man of dark ambition gentlemen red mop
through the 29th president with these
United States and to our very good
fortune
[Music]
[Applause]
driven by impressions beyond his control
and beyond the realm of virgin
mr. Harding I believe you're flirting
consumed by a lust that would not weaken
[Music]
[Applause]
his name was synonymous with grace and
dignity President to pay the price of
power
mr. president I must ask you again to
sign an executive order about this
teapot don't matter you will find this
document in between duty and desire I
demand to see my warrant young lady
you're a position to demand anything any
this way you can look me in the eyes and
tell me she means nothing to you don't
you for your back on me warrant do this
all yell dear if you don't contain the
situation this whole administration is
going down to you near me we will all be
finished my greatest man also be my
greatest trial the New York Times calls
it a movie
the LA Times leaves there are four Oscar
nominations seriously and world of
whites monthly Hales Hardy has a triumph
Campbell Scott Anna Kendrick Michael
McKee
James crumble and Laura live you
are a great man one but heed my warning
even great men may be corrupted
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
did your fall
we don't even know what we're doing with
the other pool yet
[Applause]